be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is be a little
bit dangerous and I'm going to shoot
from the hip on this video but I want to
have a discussion on how to kill
Wolverine and Deadpool permanently now
this discussion requires us to ignore a
couple things the most notable being
these storylines the death of Wolverine
and the death of Deadpool now I know it
seems kind of weird that we have to do
that but the death of Wolverine
basically just dealt with Logan being
covered in adamantium from head-to-toe
and it seemed as though it basically
suffocated him and he ended up dying the
death of Deadpool was a storyline that
basically led up to the in a Deadpool
story they didn't really kill him off
per se he basically just died like
everybody else with the collapse of the
multiverse leading up to Secret Wars now
as some of you guys may have noticed
though we did talk about how to kill
Wolverine as part of our discussion on
the Xavier protocols but the Xavier
protocols was a concept designed to kill
mutants using the powers and abilities
of other mutants and so we're actually
going to deviate away from this because
even then that's not necessarily
permanent it's not necessarily something
that would last forever however we're
going to talk about here in this video
will be a permanent solution to the
lives of Wolverine and Deadpool now the
way that we're going to kill them is
actually going to be really interesting
here in Marvel Comics you have two types
of substances that can disrupt healing
factors and each one does it in two
different ways or I guess in a different
way the first is called carbonadium now
carbonadium is basically Russia's
version of adamantium when adamantium
was created when it was effectively
synthesized by accident in an attempt to
duplicate the material of Captain
America shield it was bonded to
Wolverine skeleton it was bonded to two
Sabretooth who was bonded to maybe one
or two other people but the result is
that it is a super hard material that is
Nayan breakable the only exception of
that depending on the circumstances that
I can think of is enchanted over metal
which is the material that makes up
Thor's hammer but even then that's kind
of so-so it depends on who's writing at
the time but historically the true
adamantium the adamantium bond it's
Wolverines bones is indestructible it
cannot be destroyed by any known means
of course barn cosmic entities or
something like that but carbonadium
basically slows the healing factor
of those individuals who come into
contact with it now the most notable use
of carbonadium in Marvel Comics is with
the tentacles of Omega Red he is of
course a super popular villain among
certain circles those individuals who
were who were huge fans of will reign
but he is one of Wolverines biggest
enemies and he routinely uses his
carbonating of tentacles to disrupt the
healing factor of Wolverine to kind of
put him on an even playing field and in
the battle just sort of commences as it
would you know in Marvel Comics the
other part of this or the other aspect
of this is what's called the Muramasa
blade now the Muramasa blade was created
by a guy named Muramasa and there's
actually two different versions of them
there's what's called the black blade
and there's what's called the true
Muramasa blade now we're gonna be
talking about the second one and the
reason why is because the first one
isn't really relevant to our discussion
here the second Muramasa blade was
forged at the request of Wolverine
himself and what had happened was during
Logan's time before he joined the x-men
before he was part of Canada's
Department K when he first met I guess
hoped for the first hammer first battled
him for the first time you know when he
first appeared in comics basically um he
had traveled around the world he'd had a
lot of different experiences things like
that but he had started a family with a
woman named named it su or ET I'm not
sure exactly how to pronounce hat but
the result was that she was killed and
his child was killed and so in response
to the revenge that he sought he went
out and found a guy named Muramasa now
we don't know much about Muramasa
himself all we know is that he's
basically like you know the Marvel
Comics equivalent of Ettore Hanzo from
Kill Bill if any of you guys are
familiar with that movie uh he is a
master swordsman and he's basically like
the one guy that all of the individuals
villains and heroes alike in Marvel
Comics to use swords go to taskmaster
went to Muramasa Deadpool went to
Muramasa to have his blades forged of
course we know Wolverine went to
Muramasa to get his own sword but
instead of simply just forging a sword
at the behest of its wielder depending
on the purpose
Muramasa will actually imbue the sword
with the essence of the individual
themselves in the case of the Muramasa
blade it was imbued with the essence of
Wolverine spirit his rage his anger his
desire for revenge and that made the
sword strong
the result of this was that the Muramasa
blade was designed for the purpose of
killing anybody who came into contact
with it including Wolverine himself now
this is kind of a misnomer one of the
reasons why I say that is the indication
that Marvel gives us is that the the
Muramasa blade negates healing factors
but when it says or when Marvel says
that the Muramasa blade will kill
Wolverine himself it's not really the
blade directly that does it and there's
a big distinction here the carbonadium
slows healing factors the Muramasa blade
negates healing factors but in order to
kill a person you're still required to
basically kill them through conventional
means and this is where killing you know
Wolverine and Deadpool permanently comes
into play with something like
carbonadium if you were to assault
Wolverine with it his healing factor
would be slowed extremely it would take
him a long time to recover but you could
still do it in the same capacity that
you could you know remove a limb
assuming he cut through you know the
adamantium remove his head from his body
the only way that could ever really be
done is again by using something like
carbonadium to slow it down but if you
have a Muramasa blade that healing
factor goes away now as far as I'm aware
there's no actual time frame I think
it's just contextual based on the story
so the one writer may say that it takes
a day for Wolverines healing factor to
come back after being attacked with the
Muramasa blade another writer may say
that it takes three months another
writer may say it takes a year where it
may take years we have no idea it really
just depends on what the writer wants to
do at the time because the Muramasa
blade is not something that you see very
often in Marvel Comics but the fact
remains that by killing Wolverine in
this fashion you'll basically remove his
healing factor in its entirety the catch
to this or the caveat is because the
Muramasa Blake entails an essence of
Wolverine soul itself it's entirely
possible to absorb the entirety of
Wolverine soul into the Muramasa blade
and destroy his body in its entirety
basically take like turn his turn his
body into a shell more or less and he
would just reside inside the blade and
he wouldn't be able to reconstitute
himself he would actually have to put
his soul back in his body and then he
would start to heal again but again this
is all just kind of contextual we're
just kind of were left to our own
devices on this and a lot of ways but
with deadpool it's a little trickier in
Marvel Comics
Deadpool's immortality is attributed to
a curse he was cursed by Thanos with
immortality out of jealousy for the fact
that mistress death showed affection
towards Deadpool and didn't show
affection towards Thanos but the issue
with their so one of the big
misconceptions about this is that
Deadpool is genuinely immortal in Marvel
Comics there's a huge difference between
being genuinely immortal and being
immortal by virtue of something else
genuine immortals are people like Gideon
who is what's called an external
basically an inner group of mutants who
are legitimately immortal and cannot be
killed by any known means except for
when he died and I know it seems kind of
weird but there are different kinds of
external there's a character named
Selene she's believed to be an external
not really sure about that but she is
the oldest Whedon alive but she has to
absorb the energy of others in order to
keep herself a lot and she absorbed the
life energies of Gideon effectively
absorbed his soul which seemed to kill
him in the process and so again with the
example of Wolverine it turned Gideon's
body into into a shell there was really
nothing there aside from something like
that Gideon will always come back he
will always find a way to reconstitute
himself now this doesn't take into
account chopping his head off and
removing it we'd have to assume that
like Wolverine the head would have to be
reconnected to the body or it may be
that he would grow a new head the I as
far as I know there's never been an
instance from almost explored that
storyline in their comics so really what
its kind of left to our own guesses here
but the fact remains that with with
Deadpool he's not genuinely immortal his
healing factor has basically been
boosted to the most extreme form that he
will heal from anything so in you know
funeral for freak which is where the
curse was verified by Thanos He healed
himself from a single hand but this
requires that he heal it requires that
his healing factor be intact and so
again using something like the Muramasa
blade you could negate his healing
factor and then you could incinerate the
entirety of his body or something like
that um you could negate his healing
factor and then you could you know well
I guess I'd really be the only way now
somebody else that we kind of need to
touch on here something else that I want
to I want to have a discussion on is and
the story Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe Deadpool himself actually
talked about how to negate his own
healing factor and what he said was when
he when that alternate reality version
of himself went around and was
hacking the x-men various people like
that he had kidnapped take in the son of
Wolverine and x-23 I think it was and he
had basically forced their bodies to
endure
electroshock over and over and over
again in order to keep their healing
powers at bay now this story I believe
came before the Muramasa blade and so
this was that wasn't really a concept in
existence that they could explore but in
Marvel Comics there is also something
called burning out a healing factor
Wolverines healing factor can burn out
it can he can heal his body so many
times or he can heal his body from such
an extreme event that like a muscle
it'll tire out think of it like a human
heart if you run too hard or if you if
you lift too many weights I don't know
your heart will give out and it'll
basically stop we call that a heart
attack with healing factors is the exact
same way so I guess a healing factor
attack if the result is that the healing
factor will simply just stop working now
this is usually temporary with the
characters like Wolverine and Deadpool
this is temporary Marvel usually throws
us into the story as a way to experiment
to see if fans would read stories where
they didn't have healing factors but the
fact remains that a healing factor can
burn out it can stop working after a
time but again at this point we're just
talking about how to kill them
permanently the the only feasible way
that I know of in Marvel Comics to
effectively kill Wolverine and Deadpool
permanently is to attack them with the
Muramasa blade negate their healing
factors and then incinerate their bodies
in their entirety the only issue with
this again comes with Wolverine but you
know that's again this is really just
kind of hypothetical stuff that we're
talking about here so anyway if you guys
can think of any cool ways to kill
Wolverine I'm kind of curious post a
comment down below let me know what you
guys think and yeah
we'll catch you all in it peace
[Music]
you